citizens of the reject nation greg here
john
what's up not much man i'm excited to
watch a film theory yeah
listen guys
i'm sorry i'm committing the carnal sin
of wearing a batman shirt i just
realized that we shot some different
videos okay it's okay marvel carter it's
part of our a brand that we we wear apt
shirts it's okay i screwed up on the
other videos so this this
yeah i was wearing a marvel shirt that
whole time
huge
i know might not even release that video
we might not release this one let's see
what happens
which timeline do we have
everywhere yeah we're gonna watch the
film theorist ant-man will die
this is not a theory this is just a fact
uh ant-man and the wasp quantomania you
know and people age my theory has been
that uh hank pym's gonna die
i think hope and janet van dyne and the
rest of the female cast will all die
yeah cassie lange answers the photo
frame
film i messed the joke up guys it's okay
i'll leave a like let's watch it
let's just cut to the chase friends
while the rest of the world is getting
ready to see black panther wakanda
forever in a few months i've got my eyes
set to the movie right after it ant-man
quantum mania why should i care about
the third movie in the ant-man trilogy
oh because that's where ant-man is gonna
die and i'm about to prove it to you
let's see about this matthew the pat
don't take my scott train welcome to
film theory where the smallest details
transform into huge pieces of evidence
case in point today's episode you see
even before this year's comic con it'd
been pretty well established that kang
the conqueror was gonna be the mcu's
next thanos level overarching threat
there's been no shortage
confirming that when it comes to marvel
this is the guy that you're gonna need
to watch out for and now that the next
avengers movie is straight up called the
kang dynasty forget about it case closed
don't get up we got in our first tease
of kang and then with this big over
excited exposition dump during the final
episode of loki but in the comics he's
actually a multiversal warmonger a guy
who lives with the unlimited lives cheat
code
infinite violent variants floating
around the infinite timelines kang's
future technology is so advanced that
he's able to transfer his consciousness
to a new body at the moment of his death
the dudes like rick sanchez minus the
existential apathy and don't get me
wrong a citadel of rick's versus
avengers showdown is certainly
interesting in theory but it ultimately
might ring hollow if there's no stakes
behind it thanos wasn't just an era
defining villain because he was powerful
if we learned anything from that galaxy
brain grimace a box office mega villain
needs to earn their place by altering
the status quo drastically they need to
squat they're an existential threat to
our favorite plot armored heroes they
need to make our blood boil with the
rage of revenge and the fear of loss in
short someone's got to get dusted that's
so true because that's that was a big
part of thanos threat level but i'm
having a hard time remembering off the
top of my head who actually truly just
never returned
because vision returned in some way
everyone returned in some way
morrow's back in some way but for a
moment he wiped them all out versions of
them die
yeah
how much stakes can you have in an
infinite multiverse now where anybody
can come back at anything i feel like
there's one loki with a loki came back
in some way he's come back multiple
times but at the time no thanos real
threat level for sure at the time yeah
now the infinity stones are paperweight
kang has to prove himself as the next
major threat by killing off a beloved
hero and that hero is gonna be ant-man
squash them like a bug ant-man in the
final movie of his trilogy is going to
get exterminated like a bug which you
know is it's it's fitting first let's
start things off by examining the
general story structure of the mcu no
you can't get to the end until you've
been changed by the journey thanks for
that kang see this guy knows what he's
talking about no i mean absolutely no
disrespect to stan lee stands by saying
this but the mcu runs on some pretty
tried and true story formulas at this
point i think it's pretty fair to say
that we're all at least vaguely familiar
with the narrative beats of the iconic
heroes journey star wars adventure find
a mentor death and rebirth that results
in some sort of a transformation
atonement and then returning back to the
beginning
but exactly like that overarching end
bosses hit key beats in their stories as
well you can certainly see the pattern
in self-contained stories
turn around in chair with cat on laughs
capture the hero confess
got to all all that's missing from this
circle is a twirl of the stash
it's completely
willing to let that just fly by in this
you can certainly see the pattern in
self-contained stories but it's
especially apparent when you start
looking at memorable big baddies of epic
adventure franchises first the big
villain appears in a film technique that
steven spielberg likes to call the
fraction introduction this is where the
audience is teased about the mystery
surrounding this new character for
thanos this fraction tease came as his
cameo at the end of the first avengers
film pegging him as the true mastermind
behind loki's chittari invasion harry
potter had evil lord voldemort appearing
as just a face on the back of professor
quarle's head at the end of the first
movie showing the big boss as the
motivating force for a lesser antagonist
is a common trope that's used to express
this particular plot point think of fire
lord ozai's silhouette ordering zuma
or grand moff tarkin named dropping the
emperor in a new hope i've just received
word that the emperor has dissolved the
council permanently implying that even
darth vader answers to someone higher up
on the food chain as the plot moves into
act 2 we're given a taste of the
villain's true power it's common for
writers to give us hints of this through
the use of specific story beats known as
pinch points these pinch points are
moments that amp up the narrative
tension by putting our heroes in a jam
through increasing doses of the
villain's intensifying presence
traditionally there are two major pinch
points that happen on opposite ends of
the story's second act the first is
usually early in act two and it's just a
simple reminder of the villain's
strength the second to foreshadows the
biggest complication that the villain
will throw at our heroes often times an
important character gets killed in the
process in harry potter the first key
pinch showcasing the threat of voldemort
is the death of cedric diggory in goblet
of fire the second pinch point comes
when dumbledore himself is killed off in
movie six right before the final push
towards the end battle for the infinity
saga
first pinch point comes when he enlists
ronan the accuser to get the power stone
in guardian's galaxy through ronin we
are given the glimpse of the destruction
that'll spread throughout the universe
as thanos completes his rock collection
huh i gotta say i'm really appreciating
this video so far because they're doing
like act structures but based off of
cinematic universe build up yeah or
franchise
yeah versus like a movie structure
because i was like yeah you know like
they they kill off rachel in the dark
knight
that would be one of these like pinch
points he's talking about like where my
mind went to i'm like oh but i've never
decided to look at like act structures
in terms of franchise building yeah
there is a real methodical art see
though acts over several movies like you
would a show the second pinch point is
at the start of infinity war when thanos
decimates the asgardians boxes the
previously unbeatable hulk into
retirement and drives home that even the
slippery loki can't escape his
inevitability loki's death is the
linchpin of the pinch point without it
the stakes wouldn't be high enough for
the audience to care in one scene thanos
decimates what have otherwise been
indestructible heroes given us a sense
of the real threat that he poses which
brings us then to their moment of
victory after years of scheming in the
shadows the villain finally achieves
their goal when it comes to sprawling
franchise level narratives this moment
often happens in the second to last
installment leaving us on a cliffhanger
so that both fans and heroes have to sit
through their darkest hours
waiting for resolution just think about
the king of this trope star wars the
empire strikes back where han ends the
movie as a big old ice cube and luke
loses a hand for the infinity saga this
moment is when thanos best supports
mightiest heroes and dusts half the
universe this structure achieves two
purposes first it underlines the
strength of the threat but more
importantly it turns our heroes into
underdogs it's not certain whether or
not they'll be able to prevail the next
installment then means that the heroes
have to win back every inch of the world
that they wish to fix ultimately making
the climactic battle feel that much more
earned so those are your lessons from
the screenplay and according to this
time-tested story formula we can look at
kang's confirmed appearances in the mcu
to deduce how he might be similarly
utilized fascinating movies in order to
truly like the role of the next big bad
right now we've seen kang's first teaser
moment in the season 1 loki finale and
boy was that a journey on its own
throughout the season we see timelines
getting deleted infinity stones turning
into meaningless rocks and a hangry
cloud monster that devours all matter
this leads us to the citadel at the end
of time a big scary castle with big
dramatic doors and a massive tension
building elevator with the entire series
building to this moment loki has reached
the one pulling the strings behind the
whole operation the elevator doors open
and kang it's his thanos first reveal
moment and this isn't even a
particularly violent kang either sure
he's created a big brother organization
run by puppets that prunes entire
timelines but he tells us that all of
this is to keep his other more violent
selves at bay if you think i'm evil this
way till you meet my variants with just
one timeline there's just one kang and
he warns that his death is going to
unleash a pandora's box of crueler
variants so of course he dies only to
have everything start to unravel looking
more broadly right now the multiverse is
in flux with movies like no way home and
multiverse of madness while kang isn't
connected to either of those events yet
those movies are already priming us for
kangs and they're all possible we're
starting to learn the rules and the
dangers that accompany wild multiversal
collisions just like the infinity saga
introduced us one by one to the powers
and dangers of the individual stones via
movies that were completely disconnected
from thanos the reality stone in thor 2
the time stone and doctor strange the
tesseract and avengers the power stoning
guardians that way when everything comes
together with kang all the rule setting
in world building has already been done
in previous movies yeah you see like
this was something that i was really
thinking about the other day of like
what is it of why people were starting
to really feel like phase four is not
connected or that marvel's like lacking
connectivity as of late i feel like you
know announcing stuff at comic con with
king dynasty and secret wars is like
okay no those early theories that
multiverses will collide coming together
and you know when looking at the first
three phases i feel like with the fact
that phase one only had a few movies and
the point wasn't to who's gonna be the
big baddie the point was when are they
going to team up together for the first
time on screen like we're so used to
seeing these crossovers now it's just a
part of it we forget that the phase one
build-up wasn't the big baddie it was
just the first avengers movie just to
see them all come together on the screen
for the first time yeah and that's what
it seemed like the end points were for
those first two phases in some ways and
then after phase one started to really
become more about building up to
fighting thanos yeah and whereas here
this past phase it's just been really
who are they gonna fight to what's the
build yeah yeah how does this all
connect now come on
what's the end point that we're building
too because yeah like the first phase
took a familiar semi villainous
character and just repurposed him as the
main villain and then yeah the second
phase you had a villain entirely
concocted out of that one movie yeah
yeah it's a good question it's funny to
me that we've had so much debate about
phase four and like ah it seems aimless
where is it going but like towards the
top of it they gave you the figure who
is going to factor heavily in through
all this and the further we get the more
i feel the clarity of like oh yeah yeah
it's supposed to feel tangential right
now because it's about to all collide
and those states in and of themselves
are part of that and i feel like that's
a less tangible thing than like a
physical threat so i feel like it's
easier to overlook that all of this
means that if we consult the handy dandy
story cheat sheet the next time we'll be
interacting with kang will be the pinch
points and hey wouldn't you know it but
we have two projects next year that have
that pair of pinch points one of these
has to be loki season 2 due out in
mid-2023 this one's obvious because at
the end of season one of loki we see
giant kang statues in the new layout of
the rebooted tva safe to say that kang
is gonna play a huge role in loki's
return which means that there's gonna be
plenty of time to get those pinches in
but the other pinch point is gonna come
even sooner than that with quantomania's
release in february of 2023 and that one
is gonna be the death pinch this is wild
and here's where the theory gets
interesting loyal theorists i submit to
you exhibit a a minor leaked image from
quantomania's pre-production these
shirts were allegedly made for quantum
mania stunt team depicting a broken
ant-man helmet and the reflection of
kang the conqueror ominously charged
energy
installments of mcu films historically
end with the destruction of a hero's
iconic equipment iron man 3 had tony hit
the fireworks button on his whole iron
closet captain america civil war had
steve rogers renounce his shield and
thor ragnarok shattered mjolnir god damn
it
yeah right scott lang might just be left
to face the nearly immortal time demigod
kang with only his wits and well those
aren't great odds and i'm not the only
one to notice the power imbalance here
back in october of 2021 jonathan magers
actor for kang the conqueror was
interviewed on the late night show jimmy
kimmel when he's questioned on how
ant-man would possibly be able to
contend with someone of kang's power we
get this no offense to ant-man but kang
if kang is a thanos yeah it's like
squash
we'll see look at that face seems to me
that kimmel guessed right and majors
gives him a little too much reveal with
that facial response that my friends is
a man who has realized that kevin
feige's snipers are on the way so from a
narrative angle it's the perfect time
for ant-man to die we have t-shirts from
the production showing that ant-man is
gonna get wrecked and we have kang's
actor giving us some guilty vibes and
interviews but there's still one more
piece of evidence that you need to see
avengers number 500. the first part of
the avengers disassembled comic arc that
brought about an end to the avengers
team spoiler alert in this issue ant-man
dies now admittedly it isn't at the
hands of kang the conqueror but the
ripple effects of his death end up
playing an important role in both kang's
development and the evolution of the
avengers you see scott lang's death is
very comic booky he's killed when the
zombie corpse of his best friend
unexpectedly explodes this all turns out
to be the result of a grieving scarlet
witch inadvertently tampering with the
fabric of reality but it's not the how
of this comic that's important it's the
why you see scott's death is incredibly
important because it's the catalyst that
sets in motion the formation of the
young avengers one of the key members is
scott's daughter cassie lange is so
moved by scott's death that she takes up
the ant-man legacy under the code name
stature and forms the team in order to
avenge him and hey wouldn't you know it
but the quantum mania poster and footage
from comic con showed us that cassie is
going to suit up just like her dad in
the new movie it doesn't hurt that the
cassie actress from endgame also got
recast with a bigger name too without
even telling said actress that she was
being recast bad luck there marvel bad
luck now it's pretty clear that the
young avengers are coming to the big
screen nearly every phase 4 property has
introduced or will introduce a potential
young avenger many of whom are the
founding members of the team in the
comics one division gave us billy and
tommy aka wiccan and speed hawkeye gave
us kate bishop loki opened the door for
kid loki multiverse and madness gave us
america chavez and falcon in the winter
soldier gave us patriot heck i wouldn't
be surprised if hulkling pops up in
she-hulk or secret invasion then you
also have to consider the potential
applications of ms marvel and ironheart
who are coming and teens and prime
candidates for the mcu's young avengers
lineup clearly the building blocks for
this team are being assembled now we
just need the event that gets them all
together ant-man's death just like in
the comics but you want to know the real
clincher kang is actually the first
villain that the young avengers take on
in the
dang
comics
more subatomic on this theory if kang
the conqueror is running with ant-man
goes as badly for scott as i think it's
gonna that one kill doesn't just mold
the villain that all these new heroes
are against in phase five
it's hard to argue with this i'm so
worried that's a hard one to argue with
maybe he'll just really really severely
hurt him and though still form the young
avengers i mean yeah
i can't just keep wondering would this
freaking ball run that's the one thing
and in the greater scope of the mcu not
to say that i like both ant-man movies
but it seems like they have an eye on
elevating things from before that maybe
weren't the most beloved and also giving
people really their due and their time
to shine and as much as i've loved the
scotland appearances so far it feels
like
it would be kind of abrupt just to end
his journey here and now and i think
also too if you're following a structure
even though it's a different comic
there's so much correlating to that one
comic marvel movies they tend to deviate
from the comics quite a bit yeah
in terms of following specific plot
structures of like okay if we're gonna
get cassie laying into the young
avengers and we gotta kill off scotland
because that's what happens in the
comics and then that's how they fight
king conqueror having a hard time seeing
that the young avengers first team-up
movie would be against king the
conqueror because when they have their
first team-up movie
be them defeating hang the conqueror or
losing to king the conqueror like either
one i'm like i feel like for the first
time a movie they they'd want them to to
win right and it'd be kind of weird for
king to be subject to that at the as the
first villain yeah and and
would it i mean you can argue about
variants and whatever but would it
undercut the kang dynasty to have had
them go up against and defeat kang yeah
the kid avenger or you know the young
avengers and then have like the adult
avengers lose to him or something i mean
i still feel like in some way could be
hank pym who helps propel this and then
you know it's got a laying suit damage
in the process or it feels like such a
failure because one thing that this
movie's dealing with is his ego and his
ego could be so shattered by the end
that he loses all faith in himself and
cassie lane decides to take up i don't
know
you got some good arguments all right
you writers got some good arguments here
that one kill doesn't just mold the
villain that all these new heroes are
gonna have to band together against in
phase five it's also gonna shape the
entirety of phase six what if unlike
thanos kang gets a redemption arc and
becomes a young avenger you see kang wow
variance but one of them is a young
avenger in fact oh yes a teen variant of
kang going by the alias iron lad forms
the team in hopes that he can divert
himself from growing up to become a
megalomaniac that brings about the
destruction of the multiverse iron lad
even has a close sometimes romantic
relationship with cassie lang in the
comics this poses an interesting
conflict if kang turns out to be the one
to squash ant-man at their core the
ant-man movies are thematically about
second chances scott is an ex-felon
who's given a second lease on life hank
pym gets a second chance at saving his
wife janet the ant family helps save and
redeem ghosts in the second film if kang
kills cassie's father she's put in a
scenario where she may have to give her
father's killer a pre-emptive second
chance as well so if cassie chooses to
forgive young kang that may be the push
iron lad needs to avoid his dark future
saving the multiverse from adult kang in
the process or maybe the second chance
kang gets in quantum mania is at killing
scott when they meet during the trailer
shown at comic-con scott introduces
himself to kang as an avenger kang's
response you're an avenger have i killed
you before so when ant-man starts
advertising itself like yet another
quirky superhero comedy star in paul
rudd you'll know the truth at some point
that thing is gonna take a serious turn
and pull the rug out from under you
stomp in the main man himself out of
existence either that or you know
ant-man shrinks himself and hops up
kang's butt
[Music]
very well done
very well done great job on that video
that was great yeah very solid theory oh
i'm worried that's a hard one to argue
with true but hey i mean think of this
they could instead of doing it to scott
lang they could still do that just with
a different important character i don't
know i don't know who it would be janet
she's been out of the quantum realm for
five days
right away the first scene of the movie
like it's the 80s again
all right well what do you guys think
you think ant-man will die
leave your thoughts down below
all right
subscribe
click that bell to start making sure my
phone was all right yeah we'll talk with
you all soon
[Music]